hello hello reject a box
look why I'd like that rejected by think
I'm gonna go with that but we're gonna
check out Star Wars The Force awakens
official TV spot number one
Dan's usually here for the game trailer
is Brian here for a movie TV spot today
because yeah because yeah he's a Star
Wars nerd I don't know if nerds the
right term but a [ __ ] well Star Wars
I caught you jerking off to Return of
the Jedi the other day yeah
doesn't everyone not during the Ewok
scenes I have lived long enough to see
the same eyes in different people
that's anything I know they immediately
smiled
follow me
wars the force awakens it looks snow
yeah man hey let me watch it alright we
should watch it again
okay okay I'll watch it again then we're
gonna slow this [ __ ] down okay I have
lived long enough to see the same eyes
and different people I love the Indiana
Jones is back
the force awakens it still just as good
you know I like how they were saying
like they talk about the generations
mm-hmm and I'm and I'm thinking like you
know what there is like in the past like
what like 40 50 years there's been a
Star Wars you know trilogy for each
generation yeah it's pretty sweet you
know now I got this new one and it's
gonna introduce like it is like some
kind of awesome mythology in American
history it really yeah really is it's
like a weird chapter in our own personal
yeah yeah it's more than just a movie
you know yeah
you can't walk away from Star Wars and
be like it's just a movie you know
there's so much that then people come up
with way more story than George Lucas
ever came up with
oh yeah the extended universe is
stupidly crazy I know you know the
chicks are not what any chick I've met
that's super into Star Wars don't think
they're hot like I'm talking about the
Nerds wasn't supposed to me I'm just
saying like is that why there's someone
to start worse because they're not
attractive now you pay you are you
trying to say that my girl ain't pretty
your girl knows a lot about Star Wars
but she's not like you know V Star Wars
nerds gonna show up front of the line at
the convention that's true that's true
so how what I'm trying to say is just
our wars female nerd mmm-hmm stay
beautiful in the inside some of you are
hot I really wonder who's speaking right
now I know your eyes I have a good guess
Oh Leia you think so I think so you
think that's Leia
I think that's Leia doesn't sound
anything like Leia yeah it's just time
has passed people's voices change I know
but if I heard Harrison Ford's voice I'm
not gonna be like wow I Harrisons before
his voice is so different yeah well I
guess Harrison Ford's pretty much I
don't know it's it sounds like you could
potentially be Carrie Fisher you know I
like what they're doing too is like
they're showing kylo Ren a lot he seems
like a villain that's gonna be really
involved in them and like throughout the
movie yeah
Darth Vader always has like someone a
bunch of people show up but it's cool
and Darth Vader was able to like you
know what I'm gonna fight myself right
now
he had such a presence so that when he
got into the battle it was oh no
that's what I feel like it's gonna be
about like with kylo Ren oh yeah he
seems like he's that leader in charge
but he's gonna be wielding a lightsaber
the whole time oh yeah he's gonna be the
type of general that doesn't sit on the
horse in the back he's like [ __ ] dad I'm
going up yeah I'm just gonna walk up to
you guys yeah you know what you know
what this film also starring a black guy
meaning this is the first this is this
character in Star Wars is known to have
the biggest penis out of all Star Wars
characters mm-hmm
it's a fact yeah it's a fact okay camera
the actor's name at this very moment I
always know his name but right now I
can't remember it we'll call him Denzel
Martin Lawrence okay I don't know why
every Star Wars video I tried throwing
in some like well I try to make thrown
in some like worse black the black
subscribers think it's funny but
everyone who's not black like Rivia so
racist I just get a kick out of like
blacks lipstick it's funny dudes I'm
just joking dad well it's one thing for
you to say I feel like if I would say
that like I would get flame neck wow
clearly the idiot of the joke yeah and
I'm white yeah super white yeah oh don't
are you saying because you're white that
black people would hate you more that's
racist and that is racist and Ray I
forgot the actresses name but main chick
she looks like a badass she was like a
[ __ ] bass like in this TV spot she's
kicking a lot of [ __ ] ass I hope to
god that of like later in the trilogy
her like staff things she's been using
is replaced by like a light saber staff
like Darth Maul double sided Tommy :
that would be badass I talked about how
people have been speculating that Luke
is really you know the kylo Ren
character hmm I talked about how people
have been talking about it but everyone
was like no Ryan you're wrong I'm like I
didn't say this is my theory yeah
because I know Adam drivers like there's
scene set photos where
drivers like walking around without the
mask on we get it we get it I'm sorry
okay
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today and become
objective of just about just about
check out dansgaming channel yeah where
he does gaming videos Jim I've been on
there a few times why don't you click
this button right here to see a video
with dan and I and a please follow us on
Instagram and Vine I've been instructed
by several people who help me in my
business adventures to promote my
Instagram and Vine more so if you follow
me there that'll make them happy and you
can continue your adventure new my
adventure in YouTube I'm not gonna like
post non-stop but follow me there cuz I
can apparently get some easy product
placement there's like Viners who make
like 15 grand off of a six-second video
can't believe that [ __ ] 15 grand
oh six seconds damn welcome to business
the only time I spent 15 grand for six
seconds was the first time I had sex
with Veronica it was an hour but a man
more I can only come once no she she but
about her oh you bought her yeah okay
but don't you ever call her a [ __ ]
I don't calling her a [ __ ] she's an
outstanding individual much better than
you but follow me on Instagram